bonjour à tous
aujourd'hui on va pas de simone veil
simone veil est une fille
en seize né en 1909
ne doit pas être confondue avec simone
veil la femme politique dont le nom
s'écrit avec un v la confusion serait
d'autant plus regrettable que
contrairement à son homonyme simone veil
la philosophe n'avait pas beaucoup de
sympathie pour les partis politiques
ça va même beaucoup plus loin que ça
puisque simone veil était tout bonnement
pour la suppression des partis
politiques une position qu'elle a
exprimé dans un petit texte intitulé
notes pour la suppression générale des
partis politiques paru en 1950 et dont
nous allons parler aujourd'hui
alors à la question en quoi les partis
politiques pose-t-il problème la réponse
de simone veil tient en une phrase
pour elle les partis politiques portent
en eux le germe du totalitarisme
ont des mots très forts certains le
trouveront même excessif surtout dans
des sociétés comme les nôtres où on nous
présente justement les partis politiques
comme un rempart au totalitarisme comme
des garanties du pluralisme et de la
démocratie
et bien simone veil ne partage
absolument pas cette opinion pour elle
les choses sont beaucoup plus complexe
que ça
et on va voir dans quelques instants
comment simone veil justifie sa position
et sur quels arguments elle s'appuie
mais avant ça quelques mots sur la
personne que le grand public connaît
finalement assez peu
simone veil est né à paris dans une
famille juive d'origine alsacienne
elle meurt très jeune à 34 ans mais elle
aura une vie très remplie
son enfance est marquée par de nombreux
déménagements
pendant la première guerre mondiale son
père étant chirurgien militaire
professeur à 22 ans et elle commence
alors à s'engager dans des actions
syndicales
elle reverse même son salaire à la
caisse de solidarité des mineurs de fond
on la voit également prendre part aux
grèves de 1936
la même année elle s'engage sur le front
espagnol en 40 elle rejoint la
résistance et d'une manière générale
toute sa vie sera marqué par
l'abnégation et l'engagement auprès des
plus démunis
elle se convertit au christianisme à
l'âge de 27 ans le christianisme dont
elle dira que c'était la seule religion
dans laquelle elles pouvaient se
reconnaître la religion des esclaves
et sur le plan philosophique simone veil
est influencé par des penseurs très
divers parfois même aux antipodes les
uns des autres
des cartes avec lequel elle partage un
attachement profond à la raison
platon en qui elle voit le père de la
mystique européenne on aura l'occasion
d'en reparler
mais aussi marc ce qu'elle rejoint sur
l'analyse sociale ainsi que sur l'idée
que la philosophie ne devrait pas
seulement servir à expliquer le monde
mais aussi à le transformer
il est évident que pour comprendre la
position de simone veil sur les partis
politiques il faut tenir compte de cette
donnée faut tenir compte de son
épistémologie politique et son
épistémologie politique c'est celle
d'une militante révolutionnaire
c'est celle d'une femme profondément
révoltés contre les injustices et qui
les combattent et dans sa pratique
quotidienne
alors pour entrer maintenant dans ce qui
va nous intéresser aujourd'hui à savoir
la question des partis politiques on va
commencer de la manière la plus simple
qui soit c'est à dire qu'on va commencer
par expliquer ce qu'est un parti
politique et quel est son but
un parti politique
une organisation qui rassemble des
personnes partageant les mêmes idées et
dont l'objectif est d'accéder au pouvoir
pour mettre en oeuvre ses idées dans la
société
accéder au pouvoir ou au minimum
influencer les décisions du parti qui se
trouve au pouvoir
donc cette définition ce n'est pas celle
de simone veil en particulier c'est la
définition du dictionnaire celle qui est
communément admise et si on analyse bien
cette définition on s'aperçoit qu'elle
contient deux éléments essentiels deux
éléments sur lesquels simone veil va
s'appuyer pour construire sa critique
des partis politiques
le premier élément c'est l'homogénéité
des idées
qu'est ce que ça veut dire eh bien
on dira que les personnes qui adhèrent
un parti politique ou qui votent pour
lui aux élections ce sont des personnes
qui partagent globalement les mêmes
opinions et les mêmes valeurs
par exemple si vous estimez que sur le
plan économique il faut encourager les
entreprises et faciliter les
licenciements
bien priori vous n'allez pas voter pour
un parti qui prône la propriété
collective des moyens de production
de même que si vous êtes un militant
écologiste
vous n'allez pas prendre votre carte
dans un parti qui prône le productivisme
et l'épuisement des énergies fossiles
ça paraît évident mais vous allez voir
tout à l'heure que c'est un point
essentiel sur lequel il faudra qu'on
s'arrête
donc premiers éléments
l'homogénéité des idées
deuxième élément la recherche du pouvoir
à part politique c'est une organisation
qui a pour but d'accéder au pouvoir
là encore c'est une évidence mais là
encore c'est une évidence qui mérite
d'être souligné
un parti politique ne veut pas
simplement exister
il ne veut pas simplement témoigner
il veut peser
peser sur les décisions pesées sur l'eau
lyc
politique qui ne pèse plus rien c'est un
parti politique condamnée à
l'inefficacité et donc à la disparition
voilà défini les deux éléments
essentiels d'un parti politique
l'homogénéité des idées et la recherche
du pouvoir
alors maintenant la question est de
savoir en quoi est ce problématique
car vous remarquez et si vous n'avez pas
remarqué je le précise maintenant pour
qu'il n'y ait aucune ambiguïté
pour simone veil ce n'est pas tel ou tel
parti politique qui pose problème
ce qui pose problème c'est le système
des partis politiques
le système c'est à dire que c'est la
nature même des partis politiques qui
est en cause
pour simone veil il n'y a pas de
distinction à faire entre les différents
partis politiques puisque quelles que
soient les idées qu'on y prône
but du jeu c'est toujours de les porter
au pouvoir
entre une boutique qui vend des robes en
satin et une boutique qui vend du
saucisson la finalité reste la même
c'est le pas
reste c'est de la décoration
donc qu'est ce qui pose problème dans
les partis politiques
selon simone veil
est ce que le problème vient de
l'homogénéité des idées ou bien ce qu'il
vient de la recherche du pouvoir
et bien en réalité
les deux
ce sont ces deux choses là il pose
problème
et on va en quoi elle pose problème
alors commençons par le et point
l'homogénéité des idées on l'a dit le
propre d'un parti c'est de rassembler
des personnes qui partagent les mêmes
opinions et les mêmes valeurs qui
partagent ce qu'on appellera une ligne
la fameuse ligne du parti
mais ce point une conséquence
qu'il rend impossible l'existence d'un
pluralisme
le pluralisme c'est à dire l'expression
et la cohabitation d'idées divergentes
sur tel ou tel sujet
parce qu'on peut très bien adhérer à la
majorité des idées d'un parti mettre en
désaccord sur d'autres
et quand ça arrive le fait de les
exprimer le fait d'exprimer une position
contradictoire avec celle du parti c'est
prendre le risque d'affaiblir le parti
c'est prendre le risque de créer de la
division
canton sa partie
et faire bloc et laisser ces désaccords
au vestiaire
d'ailleurs on peut le conte était dans
notre système actuel quand un
responsable politique prend une position
divergente par rapport à la ligne
officielle du parti on parle de ligne
dissidente
la dissidence correspondant en fait de
désobéir à l'autorité
on voit bien ici le champ lexical de la
discipline
et quand la divergence touche non plus
un membre mais un groupe de membres on
ne parle plus de dissidence mais on
parle de scission
on parle de clans au sein du parti
l'idée de
chiant la rupture de l'unité
est donc en définitive adhérer à un
parti c'est renoncer à exprimer une
pensée contradictoire
c'est renoncer à l'exercice de la raison
critique
tic menace à tout moment de fragiliser
l'équilibré et la stabilité du parti
d'ailleurs simone veil souligne à quel
point il est problématique d'exprimer
une idée au nom d'une appartenance
politique
le fait de dire en tant que socialiste
je pense que ou en tant que monarchiste
je considère que
un problème
parce que sa fugue les dunes 4 politique
soto conditionnée à adhérer à une idée
non pas parce qu'on la jugent bonne
ouvrez mais parce qu'elle fait partie du
corpus idéologique du camp auquel on
appartient
les conditions de la pensée mécanique
c'est à dire de la non pensée
et ça pour simone veil ça pose problème
ça pose problème parce que ça signifie
sacrifier la pensée sur l'autel du
consensus
ça signifie faire passer l'intérêt du
groupe avant la vérité
et ça c'est pas possible
parce qu'à la limite on peut très bien
imaginer que l'expression d'un des
accords puissent être quelque chose de
positif
on peut très bien imaginer qu'à
l'encontre de la ligne du parti puisse
être une occasion d'améliorer cette
ligne est de la rendre plus robuste
dans un mouvement hégélien de
dépassement par l'incorporation de la
critique
mais non
pensée divergente ne sera pas perçue
comme une occasion d'améliorer la ligne
du parti elle sera perçue comme une
désobéissance
comme de la déloyauté
comme le germe de la prison
simone veil explique bien la pensée du
parti exerce une pression sur la pensée
des individus qui le composent
on retrouve ici ce qu'aimer dürckheim
appelait la pensée collective c'est à
dire la pensée du groupe entend qu'elle
écrase et se substitue à la pensée
individuelle
on n'attend pas du militant qu'il
exprime des idées
on attend du militant qui soutiennent
des idées
les idées du parti
et donc le militant qui se trouvent en
situation de divergence vis-à-vis de la
ligne du parti
il doit faire un choix
fidélité au parti ou la fidélité à sa
pensée
il suit sa pensée il reste fidèle à
lui-même mais il trahit le parti
et s'il renie sa pensée il reste fidèle
au parti mais c'est lui-même qu'il
travaillait
dans les deux cas il y as trahison
pour que le dilemme du militant c'est un
dilemme d'ordre moral
choisir qui trahir
et à moins de renoncer purement et
simplement à l'exercice de son esprit
critique la trahison est
consubstantielle à l'appartenance à un
parti politique
tôt ou tard le membre d'un parti sera
confronté à ce dilemme
et ce jour là il devra trahir
trahir le pas si où se trahir lui-même
je cite
si un homme membre d'un parti est
absolument résolu à être fidèle en tout
c'est penser qu'à la lumière intérieure
exclusivement et à rien d'autre il ne
peut pas faire connaître cette
résolution à son parti il est alors
vis-à-vis de lui en état de mensonges
c'est une situation qui ne peut être
accepter qu'à cause de la nécessité qui
contraint à se trouver dans un parti
pour prendre part efficacement aux
affaires publiques mais alors cette
nécessité est un mal et il faut y mettre
fin en supprimant les parties un homme
qui n'a pas pris la résolution de
fidélité exclusive à la lumière
intérieure installe le mensonge au
centre même de l'âme on entre événements
de s'en tirer par la distinction entre
la liberté intérieure et la discipline
extérieur car il faut alors mentir au
public envers qui tout candidat tout élu
a une obligation particulière de vérité
si je m'apprête à dire au nom de mon
parti des choses que j'estime contraire
à la vérité et à la justice
vais-je l'indiqué dans un avertissement
préalable si je ne le fais pas je m'en
de ces trois formes de mensonges aux
partis au public à soi même la première
est de loin la moins mauvaise mais si
l'appartenance à un parti contre 1
toujours en tout cas au mensonge
l'existence des partis est absolument
inconditionnellement un mal
pour simone veil un esprit libre dans un
parti politique
c'est comme un spécialiste de
l'improvisation dans une pièce de racine
ce pas
et ça ne peut pas marcher parce qu'il ya
incompatibilité des approches
il ya conflit d'intérêt entre
l'attachement la vérité et l'unité du
parti
et c'est tout à fait normal d'ailleurs
parce qu'un parti politique ce n'est pas
un club de réflexion
un parti politique c'est une
organisation qui cherche à faire avancer
ses idées
pas à les contredire pas à les remettre
en cause
car les remettre en cause s'est laissé
apparaître une faille
s'est donné à l'adversaire une occasion
de s'engouffrer dans cette faille
est de nous détruire
plus on tolère l'expression d'opinions
divergentes au plus on brouille la lie
du parti
au plus haut
d'un parti morcelé et inconsistant
et ça c'est très mauvais pour la
crédibilité
on peut pas se permettre de douter quand
notre objectif est de prendre le pouvoir
on peut pas se permettre de penser à
haute voix
ça peut paraître puéril mais c'est une
réalité psychologique
rappelez-vous ce qu'on avait dit dans
l'épisode sur l'expérience de milgram le
fait que lorsque les représentants d'une
autorité ne sont pas d'accord entre eux
cette autorité s'effondrent elles
s'effondrent parce qu'on est d'autant
plus enclins à respecter une autorité
qu'elle apparaît comme puissante et
solide
qu'elle apparaît comme sûre d'elle même
donc il n'y a pas le choix c'est si
politique va être efficace
s'il veut atteindre son objectif qui est
de créer de l'adhésion pour accéder au
pouvoir il doit faire taire les voix
discordantes quand bien même elle serait
du côté de la vérité
les idées non pas parce qu'elles sont m
les idées fou parce que la force et de
leur côté
et c'est là qu'on en a au deuxième point
de la critique de simone veil à savoir
la recherche du pouvoir
but la partie politique c'est d'abord
d'accéder au pouvoir
or pour atteindre cet objectif le parti
doit gagner en force il doit gagner en
influence
c'est à dire concrètement il doit
grossir
c'est ce qui fait dire à simone veil que
le but d'un parti politique c'est la
croissance illimitée
partis politiques ne possède jamais trop
d'adhérents ni trop d'électeurs
et même lorsqu'un parti se fait élire il
n'en a pas fini avec la quête du pouvoir
parce qu'alors ils se trouvent
confrontés aux partis d'opposition
et se trouvent confrontés aux
contraintes internationales
autrement dit il se trouve confronté à
tout ce qui n'est pas lui
et tout ce qui n'est pas lui représente
dès lors une menace envers son pouvoir
c'est la phrase de marc edouard nabe
sun qui n'est pas moi et mon adversaire
est donc ce que nous dit simone veil
c'est que cette logique de croissance
illimitée en train de ce qu'elle appelle
un retournement de la relation entre fin
et moyens
qu'est ce que ça veut dire bien ça veut
dire que le but du parti politique n'est
alors plus d'instaurer le bien commun
son but c'est de continuer à croître
non
en clair
que nous dit simone veil c'est que le
parti politique n'est pas un moyen pour
instaurer le bien il devient lui-même le
bien
politique devient lui-même sa propre fin
et ça c'est très ennuyeux
si le parti devient à lui-même sa propre
fin ça veut dire que tout ce qui est
susceptible de favoriser la croissance
du parti est un bien
y compris le mensonge
est compris la comprend non
si vous risquez de perdre 5% des voix en
disant la vérité
dire la vérité
reparti
c'est trahir l'intérêt du parti
être loyal envers son parti ces êtres
déloyale vis-à-vis de la vérité
le but d'un parti politique ce n'est pas
d'avoir raison c'est de convaincre qu'il
a raison
le pouvoir ne se construit pas était
de pouvoir se construit sur de la
croyance
il se construit sur de la passe
c'est à ce titre que simone veil est
pour la suppression des partis
politiques parce que pour elle le bien
ne s'identifient pas au pouvoir
le bien s'identifie à la vérité
alors on entré dans la partie un peu
plus métaphysique de l'exposer c'est à
dire qu'on va tenter de comprendre ce
que simone veil appelle le bien
au début de sa note pour la suppression
générale des partis politiques simone
veil pause les termes de sa réflexion
étant donné que la question est de
savoir si les partis politiques sont un
bien ou un mal elle se pose la question
qu'est ce que le bien
et sa réponse est toute trouvée elle
nous dit le bien c'est la vérité
on peut
dire que c'est sa définition du bien
effectivement c'est sa définition du
bien mais si on devait il ne s'arrête
pas là
elle nous dit le bien c'est la vérité et
la justice
et alors là on a un indice
parce que ça
platon disait le monde sensible et
gouvernés par des essences et la plus
haute des essences c'est le bien lequel
se décline sous trois formes
la vérité
justice et la beauté
la vérité c'est le bien dans le domaine
de la pensée
justice c'est le bien dans le domaine de
la morale
et la beauté c'est le bien dans le
domaine des sens
et donc chaque modalité du bien
correspond à chacune des trois parties
de l'âme
la partie sensible située en bas
la partie morale situe au milieu et la
partie rationnelle situé en haut
évidemment c'est une con sans à laquelle
en tant que moderne on n'est pas habitué
même si dans les mots qu'on utilise au
quotidien on peut constater cette unité
entre les différentes déclinaisons du
bien
par exemple la réponse à un problème
mathématique on pourra dire qu'elle est
vraie
on pourra aussi dire qu'elle est juste
ou qu'elle est bonne
les trois mots fonctionne
même chose quand on parle du jeu d'un
comédien
un bon comédien on parle d'un comédien
qui joue de manière juste
et quantité de manière juste ça fait
vrai
donc vous voyez à traverser exemple que
finalement la pensée de platon n'est pas
si étrange mais qu'elle consiste dans
des analogies et des correspondances
entre les différents domaines de la
réalité
et donc quand simone veil nous donne sa
définition du bien elle nous donne la
définition à laquelle elle adhère à
savoir la définition de platon
or pour platon
le bien dans le domaine de la pensée
c'est la vérité et le bien dans le
domaine de la morale c'est la justice
et l'efficacité
selon le pouvoir ça ne fait pas partie
du bien
ça
8 faire partie des moyens pour parvenir
aux biens
condition de ne pas oublier le bien en
cours de route
or simone veil estime que les partis
politiques oublient le bien en cours de
route
ils oublient qu'ils ne sont que des
moyens en vue d'une autre fin et non pas
une fin en soi
donc on le parti-pris philosophique de
simone veil c'est le parti pris de la
morale de kant contre le parti pris de
la morale utilitariste
la morale des principes contre la morale
des résultats
ça ne veut pas dire que les résultats
n'ont pas d'importance mais ça veut dire
que les principes ont une valeur
supérieure aux résultats
et d'ailleurs simone veil le dit bien
dans son texte elle écrit le bien c'est
la vérité et la justice et en second
lieu l'utilité publique
en second lieu sous-entendu ce n'est pas
ça qui compte le plus
et encore une fois on peut ne pas
partager ce postulat moral
peut choisir la morale utilitariste
plutôt que la morale des principes
est ce qu'il faut bien comprendre
c'est que la condamnation des partis
politiques par simone veil découle de
cette conception morale
pas pour elle la morale est d'au dessus
de l'intérêt
la vérité est au dessus de l'intérêt
et se rassembler autour d'intérêts c'est
pas pareil que se réunir autour de la
vérité
le parti-pris philosophique de simone
veil c'est le parti pris de socrate
contre les sophistes
et son fils pour lesquels le plus
important était pouvoir tandis que pour
socrate le plus important c'était la
vérité
il n'y a point n'accroche possible entre
socrates et les sophistes de même qu'il
n'ya pas de point d'accrochage possible
entre simone veil et les partis
politiques
dans les deux cas on a r un différend
métaphysique
et c'est maintenant que la célèbre
phrase de simone veil pas réellement
prendre sens
je cite
partis politiques sont des organismes
publiquement officiellement constitué de
manière à tuer dans les âmes le sens de
la vérité et de la justice
la critique des partis politiques que
nous livrent simone veil n'est pas
seulement inspirée de platon et de sa
métaphysique du bien
elle a également des racines communes
avec la pensée politique de rousseau
que nous dit rousseau où se nouent dit
que
une démocratie
qui doit gouverner c'est volonté
générale
qu'est ce que la volonté générale eh
bien ce n'est surtout pas la volonté de
la majorité
ayral n'est pas la somme des intérêts
particuliers
la volonté générale c'est la volonté du
peuple au delà des intérêts particuliers
c'est la volée du peuple en tant
qu'entité unis par un intérêt commun
ce que rousseau appel l'intérêt général
l'intérêt de tous
donc l'intérêt tiens
donc selon les critères de rousseau le
sud majoritaire ce n'est pas de la
démocratie
la démocratie ce n'est pas une notion
quantitative
et pourquoi c'est un peu c'est important
parce que ça permet de comprendre que la
démocratie ce n'est pas le pouvoir du
peuple
c'est le pouvoir de la raison du peuple
la démocratie est le pouvoir de la
raison du peuple
la raison c'est ce qui unit pourquoi
parce que la raison et univers celle
tandis que les passions sont 1 10 duel
cinéma mettre tout le monde d'accord
c'est parce que les mathématiques
s'adresse à la raison
et ce qui unit la passion et ceux qui
désunis
qui divise
parce que la passion à son psy dans lego
parce que la passe on se heurte aux
autres passions
et ça aussi c'est une idée qu'on trouve
chez platon le fait que la raison et ce
qui nous fait converger tandis que la
passion est ce qui nous fait diverger
pourquoi l'une des stratégies de
domination en démocratie c'est la
manipulation des passions collectives
parce que la passion collective nous
détournent de la raison est en nous
détournant de la raison elle nous
détournent de ce qui pourrait nous faire
converger et donc nous unir
c'est ce qui fait qu'on évitera de trop
donner la parole au peuple
sauf quand c'est pour exciter quelques
passions collectives
dont pour
simone veil simone veil considère qu'un
peuple sous l'emprise de la passion
collective ne peut pas être un peuple
qui gouvernent puisqu'il n'est déjà pas
un peuple qui se gouverne
parce qu'on gouverne rien sans raison
donc de ceux conduits là encore nous en
démocratie
simone veil -le écrit textuellement elle
dit
nous n'avons jamais rien connu qui
ressemble même de loin à une démocratie
on peut pas être plus clair
donc là on a bien compris ce que simone
penser de nos sociétés dites
démocratiques
mais qu'est ce qu'il en est des partis
politiques parce que c'est quand même ça
le sujet
est bien des partis politiques sont au
fondement de ce schéma de la passion
collective
puisque les partis politiques ne
s'adresse pas à ce qui fait converger le
peuple meas qui le divise
à qui s'adresse un parti politique
une catégorie d'individus ce qu'on
appelle un électorat et cet électorat le
parti politique va devoir représenter
ses intérêts
par exemple si un candidat veut récolter
les voix des fonctionnaires il va parler
de la hausse des salaires dans la
fonction publique
s'il veut les voix des écologistes il va
parler de protection de la planète
et donc à chaque fois qu'un parti
politique s'adressera à son électorat
cible il s'adressera en réalité un
groupe d'intérêts
ce sont les intérêts qui segmente
l'électorat
d'ailleurs il suffit le mot
impartis c'est-à-dire une partie de
l'électorat
un segment de l'électorat
donc à part politique ne s'adresse pas à
la raison de l'électeur
un parti politique s'adresse aux
passions de l'électeur
carburant d'un parti politique c'est la
passion collective
la passion de ses militants la passion
de ses électeurs la passion de ses
opposants
tout ça est nécessaire à la su un parti
politique
c'est de l'énergie
et la segmentation des intérêts par
l'intermédiaire des partis c'est la
distribution d'énergie collective à des
organisations chargées de convertir
cette énergie en pouvoir
et c'est en cela que simone veil voit
dans les partis politiques
le germe du totalitarisme
parce que dit elle les partis politiques
sont des machines à fabriquer de la
passion collective
cit
si une seule passion si saisi tout un
pays le pays entier est unanime dans le
crime si deux ou quatre ou cinq ou dix
patients collective le partage il est
divisé en plusieurs bandes de criminels
les passions divergentes ne se
neutralisent pas comme c'est le cas pour
une poussière de passions individuelles
fondu dans une masse le nombre est bien
trop petit la force de chacune est bien
trop grande pour qu'il puisse y avoir
neutralisation la lutte les exaspère
elles sortent avec un bruit vraiment
infernal et qui rend impossible
d'entendre même une seconde la voie de
la justice et de la vérité toujours
presque imperceptible quand il ya
passions collectives dans un pays il y
as probabilité pour que n'importe quelle
volonté particulière soit plus proche de
la justice et de la raison que la
volonté générale ou plutôt que ce qui en
constitue la caricature la passion
collective est l'unique énergie dont
disposent les parties pour la propagande
extérieur et pour la pression exercée
sur l'âme de chaque membre on avoue que
l'esprit de parti aveugle rend sourd à
la justice pousse même donné les gens à
l'acharnement le plus cruel contre des
innocents ont là vous mais on ne pense
pas à supprimer les organismes qui
fabrique un tel esprit
la conclusion c'est que l'institution
des parties semblent bien constitué du
mal à peu près sans mélange ils sont
mauvais dans leur principe est
pratiquement leurs effets sont mauvais
la suppression des parties seraient du
bien presque pure elle est éminemment
légitime en principe et ne paraît
susceptible pratiquement que de bons
effets
la passion et ceux qui vise et la raison
et ce qui unifie
la passe on crée les conflits
créé les tragédies
son
la raison créée là qu'on veut
elle créé l'union
et la vérité
la raison
c'est la pièce de notre esprit qui nous
paie et d'être en contact avec le vrai
appeler ça le nous
le cheval
cette dimension de l'esprit par laquelle
nous affranchissons de nos passions
individuelles
de nous affranchissons du poids de notre
ego
pourant bras
celle
peut-être est-ce cela la clé de l'est
texte
que le pouvoir du peuple suppose la
raison du peuple
la convergence au dessus des sion
au dessus
particulier
les dirigeants ne peuvent pas diriger un
peuple qui se dit seul
g c'est non seulement se gouverner
mais c'est aussi
et une direction
direct non
elle converse g
il n'est pas facile de trouver cette
direction
mais comme dit spinoza
oh et difficile autant que rare
je vous remercie
[Musique]